bienvenido a real 24 cuéntanos que se
estaba sobre este ataque en particular
del estado islámico hoy en afganistán y
quienes está también aquí en esta
dirigió exactamente este ataque
el estado islámico inmediatamente
después de realizado el atentado sacó
una declaración y en la declaración dice
dos cosas número uno este es un atentado
que va dirigido contra las fuerzas de
estados unidos a quien considera fuerzas
infieles que están ocupando una tierra
musulmana y número dos contra todos
aquellos quienes colaboran con las
fuerzas de eeuu incluyendo lo que ellos
denominan la milicia talibana de esto se
desprende una tercer elemento que creo
yo que es muy interesante y es que ellos
denominan como milicia a los talibán
vale decir no reconocen que se han
tomado el poder ni tampoco lo reconocen
como un actor que legitimó el estado
islámico ya había entregado
declaraciones que su proyecto político
desde el establecimiento de un califato
que incluye la zona territorial de
afganistán y es una de las razones por
las cuales mantienen antagonismo hoy en
día con los talibán bueno pero cuéntenos
hoy en día quiénes son los líderes del
estado islámico están vinculados en
algún país en particular
el estado islámico nace de una
proyección de al qaeda terminan
finalmente rompiendo con al qaeda pero
su centro de operaciones siempre estuvo
en síria a partir de la guerra civil que
se desarrolla en ese país desde el año
2011 y de la creación formal del estado
islámico a partir del año 2014 sin
embargo dicho eso una vez que el estado
islámico comienza a generar e
incrementar sus grados de poder su
proyecto político tiende a ampliarse y
por esa misma razón intentan establecer
franquicias
representativas de su nombre en otras
zonas territoriales de medio oriente y
del lejano oriente es la razón por la
cual en el año 2015 se funda lo que se
denomina el grupo jorasán que es la
palabra con la cual el estado islámico
denomina la zona territorial que incluye
afganistán pero también algunos países
de asia central y es precisamente esa
franquicia la que hoy día desarrolla el
atentado por lo tanto estamos hablando
en realidad de la ampliación de un
proyecto político que pretende unificar
territorialmente bajo la ley musulmana
amplios territorios de medio y del
lejano oriente bueno cuéntenos también
en su opinión qué podría suceder entre
estos dos grupos el día que salgan las
tropas estadounidenses de afganistán
definitivamente
me parece que es su pregunta es difícil
sin embargo creo yo que lo que va a
ocurrir es que se va a acelerar los
criterios de inseguridad afganistán
probablemente se va a incrementar la
violencia los talibán no tienen
capacidad de garantizar la seguridad de
todo el país y eso posiblemente va a
generar un vacío de poder que otras
organizaciones no solamente el estado
dinámico sino que también organizaciones
más bien de corte étnica asociadas a la
resistencia talibán van a comenzar a
aprovechar en su propio favor
en otras palabras metemos yo en las
próximas semanas y meses va a ser uno en
el cual vamos a observar deterioro de
las condiciones en afganistán
incremento de la violencia y por lo
tanto una situación relativamente
caótica sin descartar la posibilidad de
una guerra civil